all right let's take one more call let's
go to uh laura in los
angeles laura how are you doing i'm
doing okay how are you doing
same i'm doing same and i see you're
from los angeles and so
i just automatically stereotypically
assume things are extra hard for you
guys right now you all doing okay
yeah i'm a nurse so so no you're not
doing okay
you call my show and you're lying laura
my gosh
a nurse in los angeles so tell me how
we're doing
i'm struggling yeah but i definitely
um i'm feeling totally
tapped out just fried huh yeah empty
tank and
my tolerance level for pretty much
everything is that a zero thank you very
much
hey can i tell you stress manage
you earned it okay yeah i hate that for
you
um but you earned it full stripes right
yeah so for folks who who don't know
what it's like being a nurse the last
12 months give us a give us a some
insight
oh wow it is very very
challenging um especially the last
couple of months you know since
thanksgiving it's just been
i know i'm not so swear on the radio but
you know it's been a show
yeah and an age you can say what you
want to it's all good this is a podcast
man didn't even count here
yeah i mean there's there's things that
can make your toes curl
when you hear about it and you see these
people and
it's her it's horrifying like genuinely
horrifying and then in the
same day that you have just coded
a woman who is your age and was
chatting with you about her kids 10
minutes earlier
and the same day you have a neighbor say
to you is it really that bad
i mean i didn't feel like it's that bad
it's so
frustrating and it's demoralizing it's
depressing it's disgusting all the ds
except delony
[Laughter]
hey look at that hey you know what now
it's deloney too you've you've brought
me into this laura
thanks a lot um so
how are you how are you navigating this
i am struggling i am um
definitely normally a very mellow person
i i'm pretty quiet and i manage stress
in my own dysfunctional ways that don't
affect most people around me
what is that what is that oh eating
okay yeah and uh yeah
just mostly eating but lately i've just
been
zero tolerance for my kid my husband
people on the freeway you know it's la
so that's
pretty much an everyday thing but it's
worse now um
and then unfortunately i had a patient
the other day
who was very ungrateful and insulting
even and
it took everything i had not to just go
off on her and that's not me
i'm i feel really terrible for these
people and i
understand that she's upset because of
her situation not because of me and i'm
i'm not taking it personally but it's
hard to not
internalize it i'm sorry man hey i'm
like for real i'm sorry
that you're doing this that you're going
through this
um this was all fun and good and
everyone was chanting nurses names the
first three or four months and i don't
think anybody expect this to still be
going to full tilt
a year later that's a long time to live
in the trauma of other people
and to live in the politicalization of
the hands you're holding every day right
hey it's a nightmare right and then oh
by the way you're still a mom
too right and then every i don't know
once a month you got a husband that's
like so tonight tonight is the night and
you just want to stab him in the eye
with a fork right
oh laura um so what does
what does a full tank look like for you
what does
like take me back two years ago what i
want what i want you to do is
is this number one i'm gonna tell you
things you already know this right
that being angry at somebody on the
highway is
just like that old um aaa saying right
you're just poisoning yourself hoping
somebody else is gonna die and they're
not
right you know that um
and i also know that there's when our
brain processes are trying to protect us
and we stop
hearing the alarms they get louder and
louder and what your brain's trying to
tell you is hey we've had enough we got
to tap out for a minute
yeah and i don't know what that looks
like for you i don't know if you've got
a sabbatical
uh program or if you've got an ability
to walk into your boss hey i need a
minute
like this is a lot and by a minute i
need like two weeks but
nurses are warriors and you don't want
to leave your fellow nurses because you
know someone's gonna have to pick up the
slack
all that stuff so walk me through what
does it look like for you
i want to leave this call with a plan
for you is what i want to do because
there's a
bajillion people who are just like you
laura and you're such a gift
and whether they're nurses whatever it
is they're doing they are struggling and
they've had enough they can't do any
more
and then we're saying well maybe till
june and maybe until july and
maybe in the fall if people will chill
out and stop being dumb and and then we
you know it's just like i can't do any
more right so let's get a plan together
so tell me
what does it look like what is your when
your tank's full
um i don't even remember
i'm i'm a terrible patient you know like
i
i don't pay attention to myself i don't
take care of myself
so i don't really why not laura it's
been a very
very difficult few years actually
because my daughter was really sick when
she was a baby and then
my we almost lost our house in the fires
in 2018
and you know it just seems to be piling
one on top of the other and then with
covet it
it just feels like i don't know how to
find my way back to feeling that
sense of calm and so here's how i like
to
what you're experiencing is trauma all
over the place right
and you know that and we often think of
trauma as a gunshot
or a car wreck and you're experiencing
it with
a sick kid who may not make it you're
experiencing it with your house
burning down your neighborhood's on fire
literally you're experiencing it with
the political mass you're experiencing
it with
all the secondary traumatic stress of
being a nurse
and your body's telling you i've had
enough
i gotta stop and the thing that you know
that i know that we all know about our
bodies is
um if you won't stop it will stop you at
some point right
absolutely and it's showing it's showing
it's showing cracks
um all over the place so what does
processing this trauma look like what
does getting those bricks of a fire in
your backpack and a sick kid
and all of the marriage stress that goes
with this and not being able to see your
friends
and trying to solve everything with
gummy candies that's what i do
and with bourbon and what like how do
you
what do you do to get those bricks out
of your backpack because here's the
thing you have to start taking care of
yourself or i'm going to call you out
and tell you that you don't love your
patients like you say you do
because you can't take care of them
unless you're okay
you got to put your oxygen mask on first
so what does that look like
i guess i probably need to um
enforce taking more time
for myself you know not not
spending the time that i do have to
think about
things to worry i spend a lot of time
worrying
about stuff and yeah but that worries
just part of your alarm system
right and that sucker spun out what does
it look like to
what shift do you work on day shift
okay so what does it look like to get
off of
work and to sit down with your husband
and say hey i need some help around the
house um
i'm i'm kind of cracking and he's going
to smile and say yeah we know
and actually my husband is wonderful he
cleans more than i do
oh that's awesome so you've got to go
you've got a great
very good support system partner awesome
so what does it look like
um well how about this i won't put you
on the spot anymore i'll give you some
some ideas okay help me please i'll give
you some ideas
number one i'm gonna i'm gonna call you
out i'm gonna call it everyone listening
to this
if you don't take care of yourself you
are saying i do not care about those who
love me
and that's a mean way to say that but
i'm just i've got to start being more
upfront to people who are working in the
hard lives of other people
and i've got to say that to myself if i
choose to not take care of myself i am
choosing to be less of a good dad
and choosing to be less of a good
husband and a good connected community
member
i've got to put some of my wellness and
health needs
first otherwise people around me are not
going to get my best self
and so what does that mean and that
means on certain days
um when my alarm goes off my wife's hand
will slide under the cover is that not
what you think laura
she will just grab my hand and we will
sit there and hold hands for the first
four or five minutes that we both wake
up
and occasionally we'll just touch feet
this isn't a sexual thing this is
just skin-to-skin contact okay yeah
and there's there there's all kinds of
physiological and biochemical research
that comes with that but it just is a
grounding
it lets your body know i'm tethered and
i'm okay
you are also blessed you got an awesome
old man that lives a husband that just
loves you loves you right
and so that's the best the second thing
is is
you're not gonna like this and i don't
like it either this is me the pot
talking in the kettle here
we've got to take care of our nutrition
we have to we've got to fuel our bodies
in the right way
and that may mean two or three weeks of
just utter hell getting off of sugar and
getting out of some of the
the cyclical nonsense of more grains
more sugar more grains more sugar ah
crash whatever
um and that may mean a fun adventure of
sitting on your husband saying hey we
gotta we gotta wrap some stuff up
because i'm coming i can't keep putting
water in the gas tank right
the next thing is you gotta get off of
work and
especially you get off at seven you're
gonna have to be
militant about staying away from screens
and you're going to be militant about
doing active things and that's hard
after you've been on your feet all day
but it might just be simple like taking
a walk with him saying hey will you make
me take a walk and hold my hand while we
walk
and if you can get away with it walk
around
in the grass and walk with no shoes on
and there's something about the
grounding effect
of being still and being present that
being barefoot and holding somebody's
hand does for you
the other thing is is where you can i
know this is exhausting again you're
lucky you got a guy that's stepping in
is half people over to your house or go
places where you can i don't even know
what the rules are where you are
but you've got to get with community and
not talk about nursing stuff
and not talk about coding people and not
talk about death
and not talk about sickness and not talk
about politics but just talk about
life just talk about laughter just talk
about whatever
but learn to practice to be a person
again
and this is again the pot talking to the
kettle man because people who work in
trauma they all hang out with people who
work in trauma because that's we're the
only ones
exactly what i was going to say is i
don't really know anybody
i know so laura
have to and it's gonna be awkward and
weird listen when i moved to nashville i
knew the science i knew the data
and it was super weird you know what i
did i had a couple of
two couples at my house and my wife me
and my wife had him there at our kitchen
table
and i said this is gonna be weird but
we would like to ask you to be our our
friends
there was an awkward silence and it was
like hey here's what this means
we're gonna show up and when you need
something at 2 am we're going to show up
and we may call you and we'd love to
have you involved in our kids life
and it ended up being a awkward
messy beautiful conversation because
here's what i know my tendency is to
retreat and only hang out with people
who do graphic
gross things for living and i know the
science tells me that trauma is
cumulative and so when i get home and i
play fortnite or i get home and i watch
some awesome netflix show that is just
about serial killers and murderers and
then i get the podcast another serial
killer podcast when i'm working out
all that is just trauma on top of trauma
on top of trial on top of trauma dude my
brain can't take it anymore
right yes absolutely and then the only
thing that feels better
makes things go away is pizza and the
whole two liter
coke and then the only thing the next
morning that feels better is starting
the whole stupid cycle over again
right yeah yeah and so start
i just would love to be at your house
and you have this conversation tonight
you're going to tell your husband
starting tomorrow morning when the alarm
goes off
i want you to reach under the covers and
hold my hand pervy hold my hand
and then i want you to slide your leg
over and i'll just touch our bare feet
and we're going to lay there for five
minutes and you can say
some wackadoo on the radio said to do
this and then
tell him you're responsible for making
me an awesome breakfast and it's got to
be something with
high fat and high protein that's healthy
for me that's not just going to my blood
sugar crash at 10
and make me hit the vending machines and
i want you to text each other throughout
the day and check in with one another if
you got
friends you can text funny silly things
too awesome
hug hug hug hug that little one when you
get home
go for a walk don't just plop down i
want you to go for a walk barefoot if
you can hold hands if you can
here's the final thing either in the
morning or in the evening i think for
you in the evening it's going to be
better
so i want you to start keeping a
gratitude journal start every day i mean
end every day with five things i am
grateful for
you can name patients you can maybe a
pseudonym in your book just to be
hypocompliant but
you can name patients you can name a
doctor that helped a fellow nurse you
can name your kid you can name your
husband you could name
whatever you want to but just begin to
orient yourself
away from all i see is people dying
all i see is people trying to politicize
hurt all i see
is people trying to tell me that i'm
crazy all i see
is a sweet mom that i'm talking to about
our kids and then she just passes away
on me right in front of me
and all i see that it over and over i
want you to begin to orient yourself
towards looking for beauty
looking for joy looking for the good
because there is good we just have to go
find it during the season
and i'll end it with this if you know a
nurse if you know
a man somebody in the healthcare
professions right now
i'm just calling on everybody to get
this go do something nice for them today
call them pay for a meal
go over to their house and sit on the
front porch bring coffee i don't care
what you bring
um show up and be in the lives of people
who are in the nursing profession nurse
practitioners people who work in
hospitals they are
just out of gas and this thing's not
stopping that we've got to have them
whole and that starts with us
being good community members and
reaching out so laura thank you so so
much
i want you to try that give me a month
right so give me a month
and circle back and let me know how it
goes and you can say like hey i did all
that stuff and
i still hate my life and you're an idiot
deloney and i i'll play that on the
radio that'd be
that'll be fun but it's not going to
happen that way